dann machen wir noch einmal weiter mit
paul ronzheimer paul du hast uns schon
viele hintergründe geschildert der
letzten stunden da hinter den kulissen
aus dem konrad-adenauer-haus was für
gespräche liefen
eine wichtige frage ist ja schon wer
soll es denn jetzt machen kommen heute
nach und nach im laufe des tages
vermutlich all die kandidaten laschet
sparen und so weiter aus bayern was
glaubst du wer ist im moment favorit und
ja welche welche stimmen nimmst du da an
der cdu-spitze moment war nun zunächst
muss man einmal sagen dass die
cdu-spitze also diejenigen auch die in
frage kommen auch überrascht worden sind
und in gewisser weise geschockt dass es
doch jetzt so schnell gegangen ist es
geht dann ja bei der frage um zwei
positionen
die eine ist die kanzlerkandidatur und
die andere ist der parteivorsitz was die
kanzlerkandidatur angeht muss man sagen
es ist ja so dass die cdu ohnehin gesagt
hat sie will sich damit noch zeit lassen
also ich bezweifele dass es jetzt hier
in den nächsten tagen oder in den
nächsten wochen schon klarheit in der
frage einer kanzlerkandidatur geben kann
geben wird dann wird sich annegret kramp
karrenbauer erklären müssen für wann sie
denn eine neuwahl auch der
parteivorsitzenden anstrebt also gibt es
dann einen sonderparteitag in den
nächsten wochen oder monaten schon sie
hat ja gesagt dass sie also laut infos
aus diesen präsidiums kreisen dass sie
das mittelfristig mit abgeben will
ich denke es wird natürlich jetzt heiß
telefoniert natürlich will jens spahn
der schon damals gegen annegret kramp
karrenbauer und friedrich merz
angetreten ist weiterhin an die spitze
der cdu und natürlich will er auch
weiterhin kanzlerkandidat werden aber du
hast es schon richtig gesagt es gibt
dort armin laschet
dort hört man immer wieder dass auch
armin laschet interesse habe hier an
einer kanzlerkandidatur
dazu kommt dass jens spahn und armin
laschet aus einem landesverband kommen
nämlich nordrhein westfalen das heißt
zunächst einmal müssen die beiden sich
in irgendeiner form einigen welche rolle
friedrich merz dort ein
wird hängt vor allem davon ab was auch
ja was laschet und sparen und andere in
der partei jetzt sagen er hat sich nicht
nur freunde gemacht friedrich merz in
den vergangenen wochen und monaten mit
seinen öffentlichen äußerungen zwar hat
er viel unterstützung von der basis
bekommen viel unterstützung dafür dass
er klartext spricht aber das hat auch
immer wieder für stirnrunzeln und für
empörter auch gesichter bei anderen in
der cdu-spitze gesorgt und das bedeutet
möglicherweise dass man friedrich merz
dass hier schwer übel nimmt und
möglicherweise auch am ende dafür sorgen
könnte dass er nicht auch weiterhin
nicht ganz vorne stehen will aber das
sind jetzt alles spekulationen man wird
jetzt sehen was andere kam karrenbauer
bei einer pressekonferenz die offenbar
mittag geplant ist sagen wird du hast
gerade lieber kai markus söder
angesprochen
ich denke markus söder steht tatsächlich
ein wenig herz der starke konservative
man da er hat sich klar geäußert in
thüringen als der erste hat sich sofort
abgegrenzt hat gesagt dass jack emmerich
zurücktreten müsse dass es nicht geht in
irgendeiner form hier auch nur eine
zusammenarbeit mit der ard zu machen und
sich wirklich klar positioniert insofern
wird er zumindest bei der frage der
kanzlerkandidatur sicherlich eine rolle
mitspielen sagt einmal paul nach seinen
gesprächen hinter den kulissen was ist
das im moment für einen haufen die cdu
ist ein völlig verunsicherter haufen
wenn man so will
es ist es gibt eine große unsicherheit
zwischen den verschiedenen
landesverbänden
man hat das ja auch in den vergangenen
tagen geradezu live sehen können da gab
es ein machtwort aus berlin dann kam aus
thüringen ein wir machen das aber anders
ist interessiert uns überhaupt nicht was
dort in berlin passiert ist interessiert
uns gar nicht ob es dort einen
ausschluss gibt dass man nicht mit der
ard zusammenarbeiten solle
und das hat dann wiederum zu diesen
machtverlust von ak geführt man muss
sich das so vorstellen dass christian
lindner als fdp chef nach erfurt schafft
es dann das tatsächlich herr kemmerich
zurücktritt wenige stunden später fährt
ak für die cdu nach erfurt und
ist dann nicht hin dass die fraktion auf
das eingehen was sie sagt nämlich
neuwahl
und dann gab es immer wieder aussagen
auch in den organen oder gestern die
gesagt haben nein wir lassen uns aus
berlin nicht sagen und ich glaube
annegret kramp karrenbauer es daran
schier verzweifelt in den vergangenen
stunden nächten und tagen und hat
gesehen dass sie da keine
durchschlagskraft mehr hat die frage des
kanzlerkandidaten haben wir heute auch
reiner haseloff gestellt wir haben
werden ihn gefragt ob er dafür möglichen
kanzlerkandidaten hält und dann sagte er
was ist das wäre ganz interessant fand
ja das habe ich selber auch schon öfter
gefragt
also es klang so man wusste nicht ob das
aus meiner neugier war oder ob er
tatsächlich fand das zögern geeigneter
kandidat wäre aber es war zumindest
bezeichnet das in einer zeit wo ist
eigentlich eine vorsitzende gibt die ja
eigentlich das erste zugriffsrecht hat
auf die kanzlerkandidatur und alle mal
sagen ja das war jetzt noch gar kein
thema trotzdem er offenbar in diese
frage offenbar umtrieb nun wird ja das
getrennt voneinander zu behandeln sein
oder erst mal muss ja einen einen cdu
vorsitzender gefunden werden
absolut aber natürlich das was du
ansprichst da haben natürlich in den
vergangenen monaten
diese offene diskussion darüber dass die
kanzlerkandidatur nicht entschieden ist
heißt ja auch dass die autorität der
dass die autorität von a kk angeschlagen
ist das hat sich natürlich mitbekommen
sie hat natürlich mitbekommen dass es
dort in den berühmten hintergrund runden
in berlin den politischen hinterzimmer
diskussionen natürlich fragen diskutiert
wurden ob sie das wirklich kann
es wurden die umfragen auf den tisch
geknallt wo man immer wieder gesehen hat
dass annegret kramp karrenbauer eben
diesen rückhalt in der bevölkerung nicht
hat sicherlich auch dadurch dass ihr am
anfang als cdu-vorsitzender einige
pannen passiert sind dass sie dann am
anfang ausgeschlossen hat nicht in ein
kabinett zu gehen und dann doch
verteidigungsministerin wurde
dazu gab es den umgang mit dem
musikvideo rieso es gab viele kleine
dinge glaube ich die am ende dazu
geführt haben
kleine und große dinge und dann am ende
thüringen die dazu geführt haben dass
die situation jetzt so ist wie sie ist
dass sie am ende nicht anders konnte als
hier zurückzutreten und zumindest
anzukündigen
dieser rücktritt und zu sagen dass sie
nicht kanzlerkandidaten werden will
markus söder du hast das gerade noch mal
angesprochen will er tatsächlich
kandidat werden ja oder nein auch da
gibt es im cdu lager unterschiedliche
ansichten die einen sagen natürlich
würde friedrich merz ist machen wenn er
denn gefragt wird wenn man sozusagen zu
der erkenntnis käme lieber markus söder
es gibt niemanden bewusst jetzt diese
union retten und kanzlerkandidat werden
dann gibt es einige die sagen nein das
ist zu früh er ist ja gerade erst
bayerischer ministerpräsident geworden
und er will dieses amt jetzt nicht
riskieren und schon gleich in die
nächste kanzlerkandidatur gehen aber es
gibt jetzt nicht mehr allzuviele es gibt
natürlich jens spahn der in den
diskussionen genannt wird er aber auch
in den umfragen jetzt nicht glänzt
zumindest momentan da gibt es armin
laschet der dem lager merkel dem eher
linken cdu lager nahe steht da gibt es
markus söder und das gibt es natürlich
auch wieder friedrich merz der sich
sicherlich hier in den nächsten stunden
möglicherweise schon aber in jedem fall
im nächsten tagen ins spiel bringen wird
jetzt noch einmal bei uns in der leitung
paul ronzheimer letzte einordnung bitte
für das erste von dir paul du hast uns
vorhin schon berichtet über den bruch
mit der kanzlerin das ist ja auch
menschlich hoch spannend was da in den
vergangenen stunden und tagen zwischen
den beiden zwischen ak und merkel
passiert ist wann ist dieser bruch
passiert erst jetzt oder möglicherweise
schon viel früher und das war jetzt das
endgültige resultat
sie bat das lässt sich natürlich im
einzelnen nicht eins zu eins
rekonstruieren weil irgendwie beiden da
vor allem in gesprächen miteinander
glaube ich das vertrauen nicht mehr
gefunden haben aber klar ist das ist
natürlich ein schwächezeichen war für ak
dass merkel zuletzt aus afrika
einschreiten musste
wie man hört weil man auch nicht einig
darüber komplett wie mit der lage in
thüringen umzugehen
und vorher so haben hören wir gab es
immer wieder meinungsverschiedenheiten
zwischen den beiden wie mit der partei
umzugehen ist aber auch wie mit der
führungsfrage wie man damit umzugehen
ist soll sie in das kabinett eintreten
was sie dann ja getan hat oder nicht
und zuletzt auch die frage wie geht man
jetzt mit der kanzlerkandidatur ist was
ich höre was wir gehört haben ist dass
merkel jetzt in die entscheidung des
rücktritts von aa kk zumindest gestern
gestern abend nicht eingebunden war dass
sie sich damit den stellvertretern
besprochen hat dass sie darüber
diskutiert hat wie es hier weitergehen
soll das sie dann von ihren
stellvertretern offenbar keine
rückendeckung bekommen hat unabhängig
von dieser frage lieber k gibt es aber
in diesen minuten und ich habe da
informationen gehört eine wirklich
schwierige sitzung im konrad adenauer
haus also das präsidium das dort tagt
und dort hört man dramatisches unter
anderem hat kanzlerin merkel in einem
appell an die mitglieder gerichtet und
gesagt dass man sich bei der
kanzlerkandidatur nicht unter druck
setzen lassen solle jetzt also sie
versucht auf zeit zu spielen
gleichzeitig gab es scharfe kritik an in
loyalitäten durchstechereien dort hat
sich unter anderem unions fraktionschef
ralph brinkhaus gerade eben auch zu wort
gemeldet und wolfgang schäuble
der bundestagspräsident eine legende
sozusagen in der cdu hat dort gesagt
wenn wir so weitermachen wenn wir in
diesem zustand wie er jetzt ist
weitermachen dann wird es keiner der aus
der cdu schaffen also wirklich
dramatische worte die dort für die lage
der cdu in diesem jahr wahrscheinlich
historischen stunden muss man sagen
gefunden werden also lieber keine
dramatische präsidiumssitzung in diesen
stunden im konrad-adenauer-haus alle
melden sich zu wort kritisieren wie hier
miteinander umgegangen wie
wie die situation nach thüringen war der
ihr konkurrenz sozusagen lange zeit und
jetzt favorit auf möglicherweise oder
einer der favoriten auf die nachfolge
jens spahn hat sich ebenfalls geäußert
hat sich bedankt bei annegret kramp
karrenbauer dass die cdu und csu wieder
zusammen geführt habe gleichzeitig so
sagt er aber wenn man so viele wähler im
osten verliert dann müssen wir uns die
frage stellen ob wir da richtig
aufgestellt sind also es findet hier
gerade in diesen minuten während wir
live sind eine dramatische aufarbeitung
der situation statt
wieviel glaubst du denn von diesem frust
geht mit der kanzlerin nach hause also
wird man ihr das anlassen zu sagen das
war ein riesenfehler wie wir einen blick
hat gerade gehört haben
die die kanzler und parteivorsitzenden
nicht getrennt sein
und dass sie darauf bestanden hat das
ist für die partei einfach schädlich
gewesen
ja ich gehe fest davon aus das ist
natürlich jetzt noch viel mehr auch
wieder diskussionen um kanzlerin merkel
geben wird denn wir müssen uns das ja so
vorstellen bis zu dem zeitpunkt als a kk
hier den parteivorsitz übernommen hat
als sie als merkel darauf verzichtet hat
ging eigentlich jede innerparteiliche
kritik am ende mit merkel nach hause und
das ist ja nur dadurch sozusagen
verändert worden dass ak plötzlich im
rampenlicht stand dass plötzlich die
parteikollegen auf sie geschossen haben
dass sie gesagt haben sie führt nicht
und das am ende hat merkel ja in so eine
gewisse präsidiale rolle fasst gebracht
sie konnte im ausland außenpolitik
machen sie konnte dort als große
versöhnen auch darstellen in den
koalitionsfragen als sozusagen
stabilitätsanker für deutschland aber
gleichzeitig die innerparteilichen
diskussion also die zukunftsfrage der
cdu
wie geht man mit der afg um wie geht man
damit um dass die cdu auch in den
umfragewerten immer weiter abgesackt
sind denn das müssen wir uns mehr vor
augen führen die cdu ist teilweise noch
fünf prozent entfernt von den grünen all
diese diskussionen ging am ende
dkk nach hause und am ende auch mit
ihren umfragewerten und was wir da in
diesen minuten ich habe es ja gerade
schon erzählt im konrad adenauer haus
erleben ist schon eine knallharte
aufarbeitung dessen was hier in den
vergangenen stunden passiert ist aber
auch in den vergangenen tagen und ich
gehe fest davon aus dass natürlich hier
auch die kanzlerin wieder ins zentrum
der kritik rücken wird und wenn wir da
ich habe es gerade schon gesagt
bundestagspräsident wolfgang schäuble
nicht hören das ist ja eine interne
sitzung das sind informationen die zu
uns kommen in diesen minuten oder zu mir
kommen in diesen minuten sagt dass wenn
wir so weitermachen ist kein kandidat
von uns schaffen wird das ist wirklich
das sind wirklich dramatische worte die
dort gefunden werden